this area here what's like a rap about
your fourth stroke my fourth strap very
good yes I used to have an American
accent it was so shocking wasn't it
happened
okay having four strokes it feels feels
very insensitive when you say it you
know because Mike and Keith know each
other
Mike is very charming and Keith was
still in the room right so it was it was
fun whereas your Center like yeah [ __ ]
him
with their broken brains
but it's what you asked for and you know
it's not as boring as Boris Johnson so
yeah four strokes um people over here
what would you like a rap about
medium-sized penises medium-sized
penises great yeah
you know I think you could just say
penises and we've just
by definition right
I guess
um medium-sized penises
middle of the room
step it up a notch
you said a what
life in a post-apocalyptic world what
caused the Apocalypse
[Music]
rabbits
[ __ ] okay
life in a post-apocalyptic World brought
upon by rabbits
people over here would you like a rap
battle
of course
you're not over there but yeah why not
uh when it comes how many abortions have
you had slash paused
I just want to know your your relation
to it
you performed how many
two so either you are a very
inexperienced doctor
or just a very Cavalier civilian
okay I'm doing real Grassroots abortion
work out there
don't just stand there with a sign and
go
go you know I [ __ ] get my hands dirty
right the man who's performed two
abortions look that's what happens when
you're too slow suggesting something in
this section and the man over there says
something that we're all really so far
like your suggestion again it was a bit
weird but at least it wasn't penises
strokes and abortions
from three look I've not asked your
pronouns but you're all [ __ ] blokes
aren't you foreign
[Music]
I know the name Miranda Priestley why is
that Devil Wears Prada yes so she's the
essentially the editor of Vogue right
that's the cool on Safari nice message
do yourself go on safaris no no no what
was it with the Judgment dripping from
your voice no that's a type of [ __ ] a
fashion editor would do Chris
Miranda Priestley on a safari a man is
done to abortions a medium-sized penis
so that's a popular rabbit World in four
strokes this is what you've asked for
and this is what you should get so uh
let's band let's let's do something
[Music]
drums are loud aren't they
thank you
I just wait for the Baseline I'm excited
to hear it
because this is every night every night
I'm different every night they're
different as well so you know it's the
first time I've heard this and it sounds
entirely in my wheelhouse so let's have
some fun
three suggestions from these blocks one
guy spoke loud shout four strokes one
two three that's a quad walking there
got the brain clock with the blood in
the brain and it feels so bad feel the
pain in your right arm shoulder side
you're like oh [ __ ] can't move properly
kind of Me no Hopscotch for me I'm
unstable on my feet you gotta get that
blood thinner can't be beat I'm not
making light of the situation maybe I
could myself locate them calm down go to
the doctor have you got any medication
or knocker but maybe I give respect to a
person getting two strokes then having
sex life running there yeah you seen
this the man out there shouting our
penis yeah I might meet in the street
and I say you are what you eat what that
makes no sense walk the walk talk the
talk maybe chop back a quarter report
that's a tiny bit of slang for the dick
when I see that maybe I could pick it
out of a lineup leather size there six
foot no my eyes are usually 5.5 kind of
slimsy who said that Kinsey that's the
sex scientist this is like usually you
can measure this oh welcome you must be
so confused what's he doing I just went
to the Loo and he's rapping about a
penis five inches you've seen this
summer enough whip it out his fight or
to stand there when I'm at the urinal I
love the guy to the left I feel like a
baller why because his is much much
smaller and then the guy he's in charge
he's over there [ __ ] hell is ever so
lifeless tickling the back of the wall
I'm like man step back I'm appalled at
this course correcting I see this rabbit
respective it's all kind yeah you chose
this rabbit apocalypse mix and mitosis
probably that's that disease coming out
the mouth and they dribble with ease I'm
like calm down rabbits please you know
read that book called The Road about the
apocalypse I'm like whoa in the
apocalyptic post period maybe there's a
nuclear war but no animals [ __ ] down
on the floor like yeah I'm gonna [ __ ]
shag it what's the world there's like
too many rabbits they're taking all the
resources rabbits basically more more
than horses in the growing to enormous
size and try and get bald water that
FEMA provide they bring it to me being a
big boss I'm like this is like the last
of us not one but two when it's 20 years
on ah yeah we'll have a [ __ ] one not
the abortion we're saving that right to
the end that's what you chills here
keeping it on Trend your life ah wait
v-roll they can't do it so I'll have a
go out to the doctor's office I've got a
lot of skills
watch this yeah you spot it I got a cold
hanger in my pocket I'll pull that out
and I wiggle around and the baby comes
out like beef that's ground that's
disgusting why would I even say that's
the person easily all right I might
charm these we're gonna rock out on
Safari I see that lady yes I please see
that editor call Miranda Priestly where
is she I don't mean to offend you but
friendly you're writing that Vogue in
Kenya on the Maasai Mara third place
she's a little giraffe with his face
like oh you're nice oh you're big is she
French I don't know she's a pig in New
York say she's really mean Devil Wears
Prada I'm Keen to go back to this yeah
you know I've got them Louboutins red
shoes on the bottom but these red shoes
that are on the Soles they're covered
with the blood of the baby souls and
it's your fault yes you know you did too
important two times two like that bloke
two abortion but we double it for four
strokes
[Music]
[Applause]